part of what i'm understanding you tell
me if i'm crazy here if i'm spot on the
fear of well my man could leave me or i
don't have a fallback plan now is fear
did i use this word correctly is that do
you think women have this fear yeah but
it's a made-up fear it's a boogeyman
fear family courts are gonna favor women
astronomically and then i've had women
come out and they're like well i got
divorced and i didn't didn't get
anything my first question is who filed
so you're mad that you decided to leave
him and then you couldn't get his money
like i'm sorry i don't feel bad for you
if it was that if that if those
resources were that important to you you
could have worked it out and that's not
to speak on relationships where there's
dv involved domestic violence oh gotcha
right and you can always just get a job
after you get divorced like it's not
like you're banned from working just
because you're a little bit older like i
built this youtube channel like i
started a show three months ago and i
got 30 000 subscribers this month like
how'd that happen what you work hard and
i could i could do that at 45 too
so